if you're a woman in America and work
for a corporation run by devout
Christians well tough luck the US
Supreme Court just ruled that your boss
does not have to cover birth control in
your health care plan I'm Dina and this
is hashtag where we're following the
reactions to that decision online the
hashtag Hobby Lobby has been tweeted
more than 200,000 times since the
decision came down on Monday the
justices were divided 524 reflecting
just how split Americans are over health
care and contraception Hobby Lobby is a
Christian own chain of craft stores and
it challenged a provision in the
Affordable Care Act that requires
employers to offer contraception in
their healthcare plans at no cost to
their female employees something Hobby
Lobby and other businesses argued was a
violation of their religious freedom
folks on Twitter were quick to blast the
supreme court decision condemning it as
an attack on women jessica valenti
tweeted Hobby Lobby rings women have
lost others pointed a finger at the
gender makeup of the justices that ruled
in favor elizabeth plank said all of the
people who voted in favor of Hobby Lobby
have one thing in common and it's not a
vagina and that theme was repeated
elsewhere online one viral photo showed
the male judges who ruled in favor
smiling with the caption as long as we
can still get viagra which by the way is
still covered under hobby lobby's health
care plan vasectomies to another photo
reminded Hobby Lobby that they're not a
doctor or a church but denying birth
control is no joke considering 99% of
sexually active women have used it at
some point in their lives despite that
those who supported the decision called
it a victory for religious freedom in
fact that hashtag has also been tending
the right to life committee in Illinois
celebrated by saying forcing people to
pay for contraceptives against their
conscience isn't health care it's
tyranny Republican Speaker of the House
John Boehner also tweeted today's
Supreme Court decision is a victory for
religious freedom this is the first time
the Supreme Court has extended religious
freedom protections to private companies
that are owned by a family or small
group of people which means that when it
comes to religion Hobby Lobby is
protected women who work for them not so
much as horatio put it the Hobby Lobby
ruling did not increase religious
freedom
it in fact heard it your boss's religion
trumps yours so what do you think did
the Supreme Court make the right
decision let us know and don't forget to
subscribe